this video is sponsored by Turtle Beach
which means we will have an ad from them
somewhere in the middle of the video
also before we go any further sorry you
can hear my heater occasionally turning
on in this video I did not realize until
it was too late my bad hello everyone
I'm Alana and welcome to my channel you
are watching good gaming news which is a
weekly show where I talk about all of
the good news to come out of the games
industry in any given week because
there's already a lot of bad news on the
internet I always see people say where
is the positivity it's here and I
appreciate you if you're joining me and
watching this because the truth is
nobody really cares about good news and
it's a shame because video games can be
awesome the first story today from
metro.co.uk
um is a great one in my opinion it says
Kojima rejects ridiculously high
acquisition offers to stay independent
let's make that slightly smaller
who cares whatever
on his most recent podcast Kojima admits
he's received multiple acquisition
offers and refutes rumors of his
canceled stadia game given his close
working relationship with Sony there was
speculation at one point that hideo
kojima's studio Kojima Productions would
be next in line to be absorbed into the
company that didn't happen though with
Kojima saying at the time that his
studio will remain purely independent
more recently he's not only reiterated
this pledge but also revealed that he
has routinely received ridiculously high
offers to sell his studio all of which
he's rejected and I'm sure surprised
none of us this was inevitable I imagine
that every single Studio or publisher
rather out there once hideo Kojima
attached to their portfolio he is one of
very very few people in the games
industry who can sell a game based on
their name alone he's certainly in a
league of his own where that's concerned
too like I say he's one of very few in
the industry a lot of them are
subjective I think I will always buy a
Sam Lake game a Ken Levine game a Mike
Biffle game of course I mean my list is
longer than that but it's still very
small and I do think that for most
people Kojima is above absolutely
everybody else why that is concerned and
I also think this this is actually very
important considering some of the stuff
that happened with Konami I've met
Kojima a number of times and he is
wonderful and very friendly and funny
and very kind and clearly very
passionate about what he does I've also
known people who've worked at Konami and
worked with Fido Kojima on a number of
projects and from a publisher
perspective or a producer perspective
again this is one I know from people I
know in the industry he's not easy to
work with and that is because he is so
specific about his Creative Vision and a
passionate Creative Vision does not
always go hand in hand with a producer
or publisher or the people who are
effectively having to make sure the
thing is as profitable as possible or
releases at a certain time so doing this
is in my opinion very good for Kojima
because it means that we have you know
him having full creative control
obviously games like desk training are
published by Sony in my opinion Sony is
very create a first but I think that
this varies depending on the studio my
perspective is definitely that they want
artists to create art and meddle in that
very little which is awesome but we know
he's also making some with Microsoft and
I imagine that you know consumer
Productions will probably continue
making different things with different
platforms and different
um publishes along the way and when you
are someone who is yeah very strict on a
Creative Vision I think that this is
just the best option it's awesome it
means we will get weirder and weirder
stuff death stranding is such a unique
game I love that about it and I love him
being in this position of Independence
hands down the article goes on to say
Kojima doesn't name any specific
companies but this does confirm that
there are enough out there eager to
bring Kojima and his team into their
personal fault however Kojima states
that he wants to only make games he's
interested in making something he'd
likely be unable to do if another
company like Sony or Microsoft was
calling the shots exactly let me
reiterate that we are Indies he said on
the most recent episode of his brain
structure podcast we have no
affiliations whatsoever and we are not
backed by anyone and every day I'm
approached by office all over the world
to buy our studio some of those offers
are ridiculously high prices but it's
not that I want money I want to make
what I want to make that's why I created
the studio so as long as I'm alive I
don't think I will ever accept those
authors and I believe him a lot of
people say this stuff and a lot of the
time it's nonsense I believe that that
is the truth and man what a wonderful
position of being as a creative
I want to make what I want to make is so
rare like to be able to do that is uh
it's so uncommon the article continues
with although he never directly
references it kojima's decision is
likely influenced by his time working at
Konami where his Silent Hills project
was canceled and his name was removed
from the packaging for Metal Gear Solid
5. that is still unbelievable and this
is just another note that I mean I
always figured this was the case but um
just to throw it in there for the news
it was suggested that at one point he
was working with Google on a stadia
exclusive as well but it was ultimately
canceled however in the same podcast
Kojima addressed the claim and said that
it's completely false or at least that
it didn't have anything to do with death
stranding uh as what his next project is
kojimi has been typically cryptic about
it and has spent more time teasing who
he's got to star in it than talking
about the game one of the mystery
posters had fans speculating that
Japanese Australian actress xioli
kutsuno could be among the cost and
Kojima has recently confirmed that to be
the case I love her I think she's the
[ __ ] coolest very very very glad to
have that be a thing uh she will also be
starring alongside Elle Fanning but it
remains unclear if this is for kojima's
room and overdose horror game or
something else entirely we're getting
teased I would put money on there being
something at the game awards which is
next month almost a month away I think
it's on the 10th or the 8th very
exciting I know people had a lot of
opinions on the way that destroying it
was marketed but I thought it was the
coolest we got like a bunch of short
films effectively just straight from
kojima's brain that were bizarre and
full of compelling and super weird
graphic imagery like things that we'd
never seen before like I regardless of
like if that marketing worked on me or
not I just thought it was so cool like
such a I would continue taking weird
hideo Kojima short films forever like
I'm down give me whatever you want I'm
down for it I've got a package in the
mail from Turtle Beach let's check it
out if you didn't already know they are
the best-selling console headset gaming
brand in the US for over a decade that's
a long time and they have sent me hey
still 700 Gen 2 max this thing has 40
plus hours of battery life it's designed
to play on Xbox but uh also watch the
PlayStation and Nintendo switch which is
awesome and PC and Bluetooth as well and
they say it has unmatched Comfort this
is very comfy oh this is good it has
Arrow fit cooling gel infused memory
foam so it keeps you cool next is the
spelled 600 Gen 2 max this one also
works on Xbox obviously but also PC
Nintendo switch and Playstation this one
is all about spatial audio which is
always a very cool and a headset oh yeah
this sounds awesome it has 50 millimeter
speakers which are optimized for
surround sound for Windows Sonic and
Sony 3D audio
lovely next is the stealth 600 Gen 2 USB
this one is Marathon gaming ready all
day and all like 24 hour battery life
and quick charging again this one is
specifically designed for Xbox series X
and S and Xbox One and boasts a lag free
wireless connection also I love the way
this one looks this suits my setup very
cute also has totally immersive spatial
audio with powerful 50mm speakers
optimized for surround sound as well
last but not least is a Recon 500 active
camo this one has like groundbreaking
audio tech it has industry first
patented 60 millimeter Eclipse dual
drivers they also say it has Crystal
Clear communication which is obviously
pretty important this is your removable
truespeak Pro level gaming microphone
this one is also supervised with how it
works with Nintendo switch Xbox
PlayStation PC and mobile so if you're
looking for a new headset remember that
Turtle Beach is dedicated to enhancing
your gaming experience with a series of
innovative and easy to use gaming
accessories check them out next up a
story that I'm not exactly surprised by
but I've never articulated before
um or really thought about super in
depth before and it's cool that somebody
is
this is from CNBC and it's Microsoft
exec says gaming is somewhat resilient
to economic weakness the story reads
Microsoft's head of gaming which is Phil
expensive is it really not mentioned
Phil Spencer only in key points
it's Phil Spencer
video games can stand up to economic
weakness even as the software maker
expects slower pickup in other parts of
its business targeting consumers Rising
prices and interest rates have inspired
investors to hurry up and find pockets
of financial markets that can hold up in
a downturn gaming remains a high
priority for Microsoft with a company
working to close it's 68.7 billion
acquisition of publisher Activision
Blizzard
every time I read that statistic
I get a little bit upset that it wasn't
69 billion so that every time I could
just go nice and then it sinks into me
how much money 68.7 billion is and the
fact that I can't even fathom that
amount of money
that like anything over a million is
just an unfathomable amount of money
like who what
why how did anyone accrue that why can
that much money exist
who knows anyway other parts of
Technology might be at risk in a
recession alphabet and meta platform
still derive most of their revenue from
advertising with the former still
relying on internet search and the
latter on social media Patrick low CEO
of networking Hardware maker Netgear
which reported a 14
annualized Revenue decline on Wednesday
damn said in a statement there was a
challenging macroeconomic environment
for most consumers Microsoft is more
Diversified than those companies
although earlier this week Executives
said its exposure to Consumers would
hurt sales in the current quarter of
Windows operating system licenses
surface PCS and advertising on
properties such as Bing and Linkedin
during the quarter the company expects
to sign up more subscribers to its Xbox
game pass service which provides
unlimited access to hundreds of video
games
uh more context here but we will jump to
Phil Spencer CEO of Microsoft gaming
sounded optimistic about the prospects
of the unit it's proven over the years
at times of economic uncertainty for
families gaming is somewhat resilient to
those issues he said at the Wall Street
journal's wsj Tech live conference in
Laguna Beach California uh this is
generally not like a super consistent
opinion but uh Phil obviously can speak
to the company he works for his
experiences in 2008 during the global
financial crisis Microsoft cut prices of
Xbox consoles in various markets as the
public became interested in the Nintendo
Wii it turned out to be numerically on
the console side our best holiday and
our best calendar year in the history of
Xbox said Robbie Bach president of
Microsoft's entertainment and devices
unit at the time in 2020 a brief
recession coincided with the onset of
coronavirus but that led people to stay
at home and play more games including on
Xbox consoles and PC
people everywhere turning to gaming to
sustain human connection while
practicing social distancing today's
Spencer said Microsoft gives people the
choice in how much they'd like to spend
if they want consoles the company offers
the 499 Xbox series X and the less
powerful 299 Xbox series s Microsoft
subsidizes the cost to tune of 100 to
200 per console with the expectation
that it will make money back on sales of
accessories and storefront purchases he
said it's up to Gamers if they'd like to
pay 10 or 15 per month for Game Pass
subscriptions they can also buy games
outright or play certain games for free
Spencer said he doesn't think Microsoft
will be able to keep the prices of games
constant forever but they can provide
impressive amounts of entertainment in
comparison with other Pursuits people
can play video games for hundreds of
hours so not a ton of info here just an
interesting
thought and certainly one that I don't
disagree with if you look at data Trends
gaming has almost crashed multiple times
of course but not generally coinciding
with a recession what tends to have hurt
the games industry more is uh
effectively shovelware
a lot of bad games being released very
quickly has had a very negative impact
on the games industry in the past and
it's not like the industry's immune to
potentially going back to that and it is
definitely one of my concerns with
um the appeal of subscription models
going forward I think that kind of
happened to Netflix I feel like Netflix
used to make a lot of very good content
and still does but has a lot of favor
for fast content and volume of content
because that's the easiest way to
sustain a subscription model but if you
look at games industry sales and the big
AAA game sales they do not tend to
decline in line with recessions
whatsoever which is awesome it's a
healthy industry it is the most
profitable and entertainment industry I
believe of all time at this point
and it's very weird that we don't get
credit for that it's so strange you go
to something like the game awards and
a lot of the presenters are people who
work in film rather than people who work
in video games and I find that so
strange video games are awesome they
should be asking us to host their stuff
they should be asking game directors to
host their [ __ ] I don't know why we
think Hollywood is cool with us it's not
video games are awesome we do have
another Xbox story here which is really
just because Phil recently spoke to a
bunch of people so news is coming out oh
this one's from video games Chronicle
and says Phil Spencer acknowledges it's
been too long since Xbox's last big
first party game but the exact claims
2023 will be stronger for its first
party output and I see this as a
positive because
I'd like to have more big Xbox first
party games to go along with my game
pass subscription that would be great I
do want to recommend
um plaguetail Requiem and pentiment
which is coming out very soon which I'll
be able to talk about soonish uh the
story basically says by the end of 2022
five games will have been published by
Xbox game studios this year but only one
of those which is obsidian's pentiment
will be an all-new game developed
internally the others are Indie
developed as dusk Falls a four to five
expansion which to be fair is very good
an Age of Empires re-release and
obsidians grounded which has been in
game preview for two years so kind of
doesn't count as a release but is also
very good in my opinion one thing we
definitely heard aloud and clear is it's
been too long since we've shipped what
people would say is a big first party
game Phil Spencer said on the same brain
Video cost we can have our excuses with
covet and other things but in the end I
know people invest in our platform and
they want to have great games one of the
big things that I think Gamers don't
realize when they're like Club is just
an excuse juice is the issue of file
sizes
video games especially when they're
being worked on in
production
are huge some of the assets and files
that you have to deal with are enormous
doing that from home without the most
expensive like in-office
internet setup that a lot of AAA Studios
have is significantly slower there is
absolutely zero doubt that work from
home or um remote work because of covid
delays things dramatically just because
the uploading and downloading of assets
or files or builds is slower it it adds
hours and hours and hours and hours and
hours onto projects probably weeks
months onto projects for every single
delay that wouldn't have existed if
people were in office and there are of
course other issues that a lot of
companies all over the world have dealt
with regarding covid but yeah I feel
like anyone who really dismisses covet
as being a delay for games is not aware
of how big some of the assets that are
transferred between users at home
actually are and how time consuming that
is in any case Spencer went on to claim
that the 2023 lineup would be far
stronger for Xbox and that the sort of
pandemic cause production delays which
saw its original big holiday release
Starfield pushed to 2023 okay let me
just say real quick okay that game would
have been delayed anyway there's no way
Starfield was ever coming out in 2022.
covert or not the Bethesda games ever
come out on time there's no way
uh Phil said we're excited about 2023
and we talked about games that are
coming which I love that they've done uh
those games are tracking well and we're
out of what covert did to the production
schedule and as an industry we have
fewer games this holiday than we've had
in a while when you think about the
launches Call of Duty is coming God of
War is Coming which is great Nintendo's
had a good year but in general I would
say we've been a little light but I look
at 2023 and there's a great lineup of
games coming that I'm excited about
getting our first real Xbox first party
games out of Bethesda having them [ __ ]
with redfull and staff it'll be a lot of
fun and I'm the hype for Starfield
especially is huge I'm less interested
in redfall which is a shame because
um it's made by one of my favorite
Studios on the planet and I love death
loop I love death Loop so much play
Death Loop also while you're here Xbox
users play [ __ ] Persona play persona
it's so cool that you can play Persona
now if you haven't already
P3 P4 P5 I would recommend playing uh P5
Royale very very very very highly do
please do it just just do it if you
don't like it you try it and you don't
like it that's cool but at least try it
um but yeah less excited about Red Bull
I don't know maybe the the co-op aspect
of the marketing appeals to me a lot
less I think Starfield
I have no doubt that that will be a
great time Spencer went on a claim that
Xbox is doing a lot more work on PC and
then it would launch a big update for
its Xbox app in a few weeks Spencer
claimed early this week that game pass
growth on console is slowing down but
the PC subscriptions had seen a huge 159
increase year on year
next up just a lot of console specific
stuff this week for some reason uh this
is from gamatsu and the article is PS5
shipment's top 25 million 3.3 million
units sold in three months ended in the
three months ended September 30 2022 and
the reason this one is good news is
because I still see people say it's
impossible to get a PlayStation 5. I
know someone who just bought one on the
PlayStation Store
um maybe like three days ago but
otherwise if you watch retailers like
your Walmart
or even Amazon you'll you'll find them
you will find them so in any case the
story PlayStation 5 is shipped 25
million units worldwide Sony announced
in its Financial results for the fiscal
year ended in September 30 2022. a total
of 3.3 million PlayStation 5 units were
shipped during the three months ended
September 30 2022 the number of
PlayStation 5 shipments match the same
period of the previous fiscal year
that's pretty much it to be honest it's
just it's getting easier to do it it is
getting more accessible give it a shot
next up I'm obviously extremely biased
in bringing this to your attention
um but go to a Ragnarok reviews went out
this week and it was a wonderful day for
everybody at Santa Monica Studio in case
you missed the news this has the review
aggregate open critic 94 98 recommended
Metacritic 94. I mean wow that's cool
seeing previous entries it's a lot of
90s in there my friends a bunch of
quotes in here Sony Santa Monica
succeeded so comprehensively here that
I'm just in awe of the talent that it
took you said and so thankful I got the
chance to play
thanks Ralph appreciate that God of War
Ragnarok is an exceptional conclusion to
a compelling Saga filled with Larger
than Life characters deep combat and a
moving score Santa Monica Studios
delivers one of the most invigorating
experiences you'll ever play um and then
obviously a bunch of tense I didn't
realize how many of those there were
gamerant forever classic games game spew
game Blog game pug games Hub gaming news
gaming bolt gaming Trend geek culture
IGN IGN Middle East mmorpg.com that's an
interesting one multiplayer foot what
did IGN say thanks Simon cotty he's
great an enthralling spectacle to behold
in an even more exciting one to take the
reins off God of War Ragnarok meld's
action and adventure together to create
a new Unforgettable North Saga
impeccable writing Pitch Perfect
performances knockout action it's a
complete work of art from top to bottom
truly an honor my name's in the credits
that's nuts I worked on this game that's
crazy it's just it's just an absolute
honor but more importantly I barely did
[ __ ] and um I'm very proud just on
behalf of the team and all my colleagues
who are celebrating when this came out
and we have more celebrations next week
and the rest at potty next week and it's
all just um yeah I work with a lot of
very very good people who are very very
good at what they do and it's been a
weird experience playing through the
game and being like I think this is
really good but being too close to it to
really know if people would like it so
it was a weird day I was like I don't
know how this is going to be received I
really don't know I'm like I'm pretty
sure it's [ __ ] awesome but I've I've
I've played through a bunch of builds
and I I see it as like a technical video
game
and I look at it very differently to
your average player and even your
average reviewer so I'm just um very
proud to even get to work with people
who put in all the hours on this to make
something that people like that's
awesome and obviously this is just um
the Press but I have zero doubt that
game is all going to love it when it
comes out next week it's just super
exciting okay last up this week this is
atomic heart which I've had people like
harass me about doing reactions to but I
hadn't even heard of it um which is why
I hadn't done any I don't know what this
game is to be honest
um but we're gonna react to the official
release date trailer right now I'm
excited to check it out so let's do it
uh unmute
make sure you're in 4k and let's play
oh
I'm this is a weird shot but I'm getting
like Titanfall 2 Vibes for some reason
that office spaces look like Titanfall
2.
a little bit bioshocky
a little bit Wolfenstein
okay I'm definitely gonna play this it's
like no doubt but I'm gonna play this
this looks awesome
even though this is obviously very
stylish uh
trailer
and I'm sure they're just actual
gameplay videos that are quite different
very wolfensteiny ooh
yes
yes Don't Mind If I Do
set an ultimate version of 1950s atomic
heart takes place in a Soviet Union in
which Robotics and other Advanced
Technologies were developed during World
War II okay it makes sense why I'm
getting Wolfenstein and Bioshock Vibes
this game has announced five years ago I
had no idea or maybe I had I'd probably
seen it and forgotten about it I do that
so often these days yeah this looks this
looks rad what day is it February 21.
I'm gonna play it done all right that is
it for me today everybody very big thank
you to Turtle Beach for sponsoring this
video and for sending me some new
headsets they're they're very
comfortable they're awesome I'm Alana
and I will see you next week for another
episode of good gaming news